You two guys do seem like,
kind of like disengaged
lovers on the show.
You have that kind of energy.
(audience laughs and cheers)
Well, for an hour at least.
For an hour on the air Alec,
it's all business though.
There's a lot of subtexts with you guys.
I watch the show lately
and I go, what is it?
I can't put my finger on it.
There's a sexual tension there.
There's a sexual tension.
It makes, it makes for good TV.
It makes for outstanding,
Emmy winning television.
I find this whole,
I find this whole little
diversion very disturbing.
I'm gonna get off of
it as fast as possible.
Okay.
Don't you touch him.
(audience laughs)
He's mine, leave him alone.
All right.
I can't control myself.
[Andy] Thanks daddy.
Let's stop, make it stop.
Make it stop.
Please make it stop, Alec, make it stop.
Let's talk about, this
movie's "The Getaway."
It's a remake.
Yeah.
Ah.
Getaway.
It's a remake of a classic.
A lot of sexual tension.
No!
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, daddy.
The um.
No it's, we did a remake
of the Steve McQueen movie,
and it really was great. I
mean, I hope people go see it
'cause it's really exciting movie.
I mean, it really just zooms along.
I'd never been much into
like, you know, action films,
you know, and we did this movie we have,
and we have a great cast.
We got Jimmy Woods to do
the film and Michael Madsen,
who I really love as an
actor, and Jennifer Tilly.
And we got Richard Farnsworth,
so we got all these
really cool little people
to do these parts. And
it really is a good film.
This is a remake of a
classic Steve McQueen movie.
Are you a Steve McQueen fan?
Yeah, I like McQueen a lot, yeah.
I thought,
what's interesting me is
that a lot of people have,
it seems to me like McQueen's
been kind of forgotten.
He was this huge star in the early 70s.
You don't hear about him that much now.
I think everybody before
1980 is kinda forgotten now.
You know what I mean?
So it's like, I mean,
but people in the movie business,
they really dig McQueen
and what he did, he was,
I mean so many great films, you know,
"Papillon" and "Great
Escape" and "Getaway" was.
[Conan] "Bullitt."
"Bullitt."
Great chase scene of all time.
You tell 'em brother, you tell 'em.
"Bullitt," greatest
chase scene of all time,
but let's get back to the whole sex thing.
Yeah.
The audience
was eating that up.
We had 'em, and you let 'em go.
I know, I know.
We had 'em.
I wanted to talk about
McQueen, and I blew it.
I apologize to all of you.
Did you have a thing with
McQueen when you were a?
(audience laughs)
I was a little young at the time.
Yeah.
No, no.
Oh man.
Make it go away!
I've ruined the show.
Now this is a return for you.
You've worked for NBC before, yes?
Yeah, oh yeah, yeah.
You worked for, you were a soap actor.
I did a soap here.
I did a soap in this building
for two and a half years.
[Conan] This is The Doctors.
I did The Doctors when
it used to be on NBC.
Yeah, back in 81, 82 around there.
And, a fun experience for you?
Yeah, working in this building was fun.
Working at Rockefeller Center was fun.
Oh, you know, what's funny
is I used to do the show,
all these guys in the crew, I mean,
a lot of 'em are different now
'cause a lot of the guys in this building,
they work on the, all the different shows.
And I used to work on
the show, and I came in,
I was all excited, it was
my first job, and I said,
"God you guys are at NBC,
they got Saturday Night Live.
"They got Playhouse 90 used to be here."
And all the guys in the crew
were very, very nonchalant
about it, you know,
they would say, "You
know, this building, Alex,
"this building ain't the same
way it used to be years ago.
"So we had Playhouse 90."
And then they all bowed
their head in unison
and were very solemn, and they all said,
"Then, of course, years ago, we had Carson
"and then Carson moved to California,
"everything whoom, it was rotten."
They think it's all downhill?
All dead after Carson.
He did his show right
across the hall, actually.
Yeah, Johnny Carson used
to be in this building.
Do you miss being a soap star?
(audience laughs)
It's all downhill, huh?
I'll get you through it, don't you worry.
Life has not been bad.
All right, we're gonna
step away for a second.
When we come back -